逗子市
これじゃあ肇社長です皆さん今日は今日皆さんがとっても気になっているであろう
肇社長のお金回りのついてのお話をしようと思います
いやーもうそれはもつろん気になってるでしょもし僕が皆さんでしたらまず連絡気に
なっていますよえそりゃもう1によりも気になっております有名ユーチューバーという
のはすごいお金を稼いでいるイメージがもちろん皆さんあると思うんですけども
実際安藤誘導弾投下と自体お金どうなってるのって思っている方を多いと思うんで
ちょっとそこでの花書庫勝ち通させていた
いきたいと思いますまあもちろんめっちゃ気になっているであろうでしょ初めはどん
だけ金持ってるのは初めはどんだけ豪遊してるのか初めは夜な夜な
どんだけ三板押印しになると思います4話動画がいるはず3節はどんな性格をしている
のかっていうのはみなさんにちょっとせようと思っておりますまあ根本的な話をし
ましょう
私はじめシャツを
修了生です
[音楽]
この体周南固定給だザどんだけがんばっ
急流はソワレん
倒さを通してはずの一つは固定給なのかって話をさせていただきますとあの
実は俺行為得て
本物の社長なんです実は込みでなんか会社っぽくなってて
委員長社長
なんですよ実は本当に社長でどうしてそうしたかというとまあいろいろ理由はあるん
ですけどもあの一番はあの
皆さんこの僕にお金の管理できると思いますか無理なんですよそうこのれなきゃだから
お金の管理ができないかのあればあるほどそれでこんなうわーっうわーっやっちゃい
そうなんで
いやほんとなんか兼ねた屋根ほど動画勢とかいますよ全然動物園から出た一家も作るし
た分もあればあるほど何でもするんでしょうね
間違いなくそれを聞きした
私のお母様が安価それじゃあまず it すいろいろ話し合って結果そんなもいろいろ
お金系の管理はちょっと僕じゃない人にやってもらおうという話になって会社になって
おりますこういう話所でもしたと思うんですけど僕無理なんてはたお金の管理できない
んです本当に多分動画作ることだけにかけてるんで今度動画つけること地下できないん
で持ちすぎると絶対変なこと
使っても誰しもがわかってるからあの訪ねあなたはホて給与って入って毎月お金月収で
ね
お金を渡されておりますそれが僕の仕事ですよって怖いな
動画で言っていたらしいと裏誘わに連絡します
すっ
テルっている
マナーままどうしたの忙しいのかなぁやばそのうち誰もかかってくると思うんですけど
そう安城あのねぼくねーどんだけど待ってもねぇ
どんどんやってもらえで球団者ってああ
であーそれが会社実はどんなに頑張っても僕の給料も分かることは
だごはんであるかもしれないなぜ頑張り次第ではなんか上げてくれるみたいなこと言っ
てたもしれないんですけど
原則的に僕が同じ金額で実は普通にお仕事をしておりますすみませんね子供の夢
ユーチューバーの悲しい現実を見せてしまいました他のユーチューバーさんをどうする
か住んでいる
けど僕はそうしておりますあの計画的にあの
バカなんでお金持ってはいけない人間ランキング結構上位に入ると思うんだよだめで
みんなが思っているようにねなんかこう
パッサーましたーーーはぁっはぁっはぁっ
ううううううをみたいな生活はダンスでしたよ
いませんところへノーツとご理解の程よろしくお願い致します
で多分ここでみなさんが気になってるんだその月収好きにどれくらいのお金を僕は
もらっているのが皆さん気になっているところだと思いますまあこれは何か
ぐだ木に良い制度ちょっとさせるに黒いんで会いたいのか
持って言わせて頂きますと
実はない月
100万円
もうもらっているわけないですよく万円はもらってないです100万円もらっていませ
ん
50万円付くかもしれませんねまあそれ以上あまりませんちょっとグロい生でいません
とりあえずはんまぁちょっと言わないんですけどまぁだいたいそんなもんですかそんな
プライン
みたいな感じじゃなくてほんとんんん oh no もままおぉあっ
ぽけ抱えるを流用
カードも入るを飯もいける大まあまあやなあっでもあっでもお金やたくなっちゃった
みたいなんでベルでございます結構それぐらいですねほんとにまずで隠さず言うと
そんな超金物っていうわけでもないですよねその分色々な貯金とかしてもらってるん
ですけども僕が手元に来る
仕様で使えるもう
犬っていうのはまぁだいたいそれぐらいです本当にそれぐらいまずでこちらの atm
に行くとだいたい残高はこんな感じになっておりますさあ
まあそれを見越してあのちゃんとね色々うまいことやってるんで問題はないんですけど
ほんとそんな感じでございます
なぜ子供のみんな夢の職業ユーチューバーでからって俺が思う存分使えるお金はもう
スレ
に決まっている実はそういう感じになっておりますて母さんでも出てくれないかな給料
についてのお話をしてるんですけど
肇社長が月にどれくらいお金をもらっているのかという話ですか
手元に来るなレーズンぐらいだよね
この金額についてどう思われますかいやー
結果ペットれますオスねートマト
ペット1-2
宜しくお願
その通りですアメリコ乗ってるとを貼ってますなんだか何とか大丈夫なんとかできます
引き続きよろしくお願います
はいすべてしますというあの家の裏者庁の見解なんですよねまあ掃除1なくなんか
わかんないとどんな芸人子が出てもどんだけ何かをお金持ってても結局いつかこう
ば積んで急に終わることがあるんですよねどの仕事にも言えますけど急にば積んで
終わったりしたり
南渓重い病気にかかったりする可能性は全然あるんでまあそれを踏まえあの僕の性格
も踏まえいろいろ考えると形が一番いいんじゃないかなと思っております
こんな別に北へなんかすごい豪遊したいわけでもないしめっちゃなんか下げ方でになる
女の子なられてうえーーい
泳い v てしたいわけでもないんで僕の趣味がいい感じも楽しめるくらいでいつも
楽しみ的なお金がなくなっちゃってるんですけどそれぐらいの感じで僕はあの実は月に
お金をもらっていますちゃんと貯金もしてるし何かあってもいいようにいろいろ考えて
動いておりますがめっちゃないと堅実が人みたいになってますけど
県立じゃないからこうしている
だけであって自分で管理できればこんなことしなくていいんですよね実ははじめさぞの
給料大体そんなもんですムーン
こんなもんだと思いますよ普通に考えると高いですけどそんなんか
長靴で持つ弱いみたいな感じではないということをちょっとわかっていただけると
ありがたいでございますみんなお金は大事だぞ
じゃあ本当に大事ほんとちゃんと届けします
me
あっはぁ